>> Todd: THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
CHATTER ABOUT THE STATE OF CNN,
WITH OUR OWN JOE CONCHA SAYING
THE COLLAPSE IS COMPLETE, CNN
HOST DOING THEIR BEST TO SEND A
DIFFERENT MESSAGE.
>> THIS PLACE IS NOT PERFECT, IT
WILL NEVER BE PERFECT.
WE WILL ALWAYS HAVE FLAWS, WE
WILL ALWAYS SCREW UP AND HAVE TO
RUN CORRECTIONS.
WE ALWAYS HAVE TO WORK TO MAKE
IT BETTER AND BETTER EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
WE LOST OUR LEADER THIS WEEK,
BUT WE'RE NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
>> Ashley: JOINING US LIVE IS
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR JOE CONCHA.
WHY DO YOU DISAGREE WIT
STEL?
>> TO RUN THE CRISIS MANAGEMENT
DIVISION AND TO BE THE CNN MEDIA
CORRESPONDENT, WEARING ALL THOSE
HATS AT ONCE IS IMPRESSIVE,
WHY DO I DISAGREE WITH HIM?
BECAUSE THE NETWORK IS
COLLAPSING, CONSIDERING WHAT
HAPPENED RECENTLY, NETWORK
UCKER HAS
OO